so I have this rectangular prism here
it's kind of the shape of a brick or a
fish tank and it's made up of these unit
cubes and each of these unit cubes we're
saying is 1/4 of a foot by 1/4 of a foot
by 1/4 of a foot so you could almost
imagine that this is so let me write it
this way this is 1/4 of a foot by 1/4 of
a foot by 1/4 of a foot those are its
that those are its length height and
width or depth whatever you want to call
it so given that what is the volume of
this entire rectangular prism going to
be so I'm assuming you've given a go at
it so there's a couple of ways to think
about it you could first think about the
volume of each unit cube and then think
about how many unit cubes there are so
let's do that the unit cube its volume
is going to be 1/4 of 1/4 of a foot
times 1/4 of a foot times 1/4 of a foot
or another way to think about it is it's
going to be 1/4 times 1/4 times 1/4
cubic feet which is often written as
feet to the 3rd power
cubic feet so 1/4 times 1/4 is 1/16
times 1/4 is one 64th so this is going
to be 1 over 64 cubic feet cubic feet or
1/64 of a cubic foot that's the volume
of each of these that's the volume of
each of these unit cubes now how many of
the how many of them are there well you
could view them as kind of these two
layers the first layer has 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 that's this first layer right over
here that's this first layer right over
here and then we have the second layer
down here which would be another 8 so
it's going to be 8 plus 8 or 16 so the
total volume here the total volume is
going to be 16 times times 1/64 of a
cubic foot
which is going to be equal to 16 over 64
16 over 64 cubic feet cubic feet which
is the same thing 1660 fourths is the
same thing as 1/4 divide the numerator
and the denominator by 16 this is the
same thing as 1/4 of a cubic foot of a
cubic foot and that's our volume now
there's other ways that you could have
done this you could have just thought
about the dimensions of the length the
width and the height the width right
over here is going to be 2 times 1/4
feet which is equal to 1/2 of a foot the
height here is the same thing it's 2
times so it's going to be 2 times 1/4 of
a foot which is equal to 2/4 or 1/2 of a
foot and then the length the length here
is 4 times 1/4 of a foot 4 times 1/4 of
a foot well that's equal to 4/4 of a
foot which is equal to one foot so to
figure out it's about the volume we
could we could multiply we could
multiply the length times the width the
length times the width times the height
times the height and I need these little
dots here these aren't decimals I've
written them a little higher these are
another way it's a shorthand for
multiplication instead of writing a this
kind of X looking thing this cross
looking thing so the length is 1 the
width is 1/2 of a foot so times 1/2 and
then the height is another half is
another half let me do it this way the
height is another half so what's 1 times
1/2 times 1/2 well that's going to be
equal to 1/4 and this is a foot this is
a foot this is a foot so foot times foot
times foot that's going to be foot feet
to the third power or cubic feet 1/4 of
a cubic foot either way we got the same
result which is good